so did anyone else find it odd that when
moon Express announced two days ago on
July 12th which you may have seen the
headlines going around all over the
world that they're going to establish
the very first outpost ever on the moon
to conduct mining operations by 2020 but
the part that really caught me off guard
was the location of this robotic outpost
they're going to put it at the South
Pole of the Moon which is what oh I
don't know seven eight hundred maybe
even closer to a thousand miles from
where humans have ever even stepped foot
and they're going to do chose that place
for the very first mining operation huh
interesting choice I mean what brought
them to that decision it's almost as if
they know something that well we don't
you know there's many questions and
mysteries about our Moon that have gone
unanswered
and I find it really interesting that
NASA has no plans to go back to the moon
you'd only talk about is Mars Mars Mars
I mean take for example in January of
this year how scientists from UCLA
determined that the moon is
significantly older than we ever thought
in fact it might even be as old or older
than the earth or as old as the solar
system itself which raises all kinds of
questions involving its origins in fact
the mysteries go far deeper than that
besides the fact that they have found
processed metals such as brass and mica
on the moon they have also found uranium
236 and neptunium 237 on the moon well
why is that significant well besides the
fact that this is seldom ever discussed
and by the way this comes from NASA
scientists themselves in scientists at
MIT I mean this isn't a secret but
nobody talks about it it's like they
discovered this and just left it alone
but more specifically and why this is so
interesting is that these elements have
never been found to occur naturally in
fact uranium 236 is a radioactive
nuclear waste which is found in spent
nuclear and reprocessed uranium but even
more interesting is that Neptunian 237
is a radioactive metallic element and a
byproduct of nuclear reactors and the
production of plutonium but this
little-known fact of process metals and
artificial elements on the moon is a
seemingly left out of any conversation
from the mainstream or even NASA
altogether I mean it's not a secret but
literally
you have to be a weirdo like me and go
looking for the information to find it
you know many people don't believe that
we went to the moon but there is a
significant amount of evidence that
shows that yeah we have indeed been to
the moon the real question is when did
we first go to the moon what did we find
there and when's the last time we've
been there does anyone else think that
it's odd that the United States in the
middle of a Cold War and a space race
with Russia would send a couple
astronauts to the moon for the very
first time on live TV in front of a
global audience knowing that there was
incredible risk and dangers and the
likelihood that they would will die in
the process insiders have told and spoke
about this before and many people have
shunned them I mean Alex Jones has
reported on this and I'm not an Alex
Jones fan to be honest with you but he's
been right about a number of things so
you can't just dismiss everything he
says altogether
but regardless he claims that really the
story is that look Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin were not the first on the
moon hence why I mean look at the Apollo
11 press conference on how unbelievably
awkward that is they lacked any
enthusiasm for it whatsoever despite
just coming back from being the first
people to set foot on the moon and being
global superheroes overnight yet they
became home and became massive drunks
Neil Armstrong did his little public
appearances as possible to the point
where he pissed off NASA and then he
went into hiding for more than three
decades without doing a single formal
public interview about his experience I
mean that's really odd to be honest with
you I think we're there right now and
that we never left if you think that
sounds crazy then you should probably
start asking yourself what in the world
our deep state intelligence agencies did
with the more than six and a half
trillion dollars that has just vanished
from the Pentagon I mean you may have
seen these stories circulating around
the news outlets for last September in
August from 2016 and then we just never
hear anything about it since then
nothing from President Obama or
President Trump it's just the stories is
gone but what did they do with the money
I mean six and a half trillion dollars
is practically an infinite amount of
money I guarantee you there's a hidden
space program we're on the moon right
now and there's far more to it than we
ever thought possible have you ever
heard of the hollow moon theory well
it's more than just a theory because the
evidence is overwhelming I mean besides
the mathematical formulas and equations
that are utilized for measuring mass
NASA and other scientists have been
baffled on why the moon just lacks so
much mass that it should have based on
all the other calculations that we have
about it yet when experiments have been
done from the seismographs
place from the early Apollo missions
such as when we threw the saturn v
launch vehicle from the Apollo 13
mission when it crashed into the moon it
resulted in a impact equivalent to
approximately 11 tons of TNT and when
they did that the seismographs bounce
with wavelengths for more than three
hours and 20 minutes and scientists from
MIT literally stated that it rang like a
bell and they're completely baffled by
it and the only explanation that they
have is that well the moon is Hollow
which raises all kinds of other
incredible questions so take for example
the fact that there is an abundance of
titanium on the moon in fact
concentrations of rocks that contain
titanium on the moon first earth show
that the moon has ten times as much
titanium than earth hence the reason why
they're in such a rush to go mined the
place but there's other questions such
as the big mystery on why these massive
craters on the moon are so shallow like
dinner plates they can't account for
they don't know why they're so shallow
and that the depth versus width ratio
doesn't add up whatsoever could this
give credence that maybe there is a
titanium sphere on the inside of the
moon I know that sounds crazy but let me
show you some more information on that
and by the way research the hollow moon
theory for yourself but you'll notice
that the mainstream just ignores it all
together and all you have is fringe
media outlets that compare it to being a
Death Star seriously can't we have an
adult conversation just look at the data
and ponder and what the possibilities
are I mean isn't it really interesting
that ancient civilizations discussed the
time before the moon whether it be
authors from ancient Greece or Rome or
even the Zulu tribes in Africa that
discuss this in death or even allusions
to the time before the Moon mentioned in
the Hebrew Bible in fact these legends
even go all the way over to South
America from native tribes from the
mountains of Colombia I mean we can't
just dismiss verbal legends all together
I mean after all
hundreds of civilizations across five
continents around the world ended up
being right about the stories and
legends of a great flood because it's
been scientifically verified that yes
approximately 13,000 years ago
there was a sudden and rapid 400 foot
rise in global sea levels and those
legends survived more than 12,000 years
so is it possible that these legends may
be true and that well maybe the moon was
brought into orbit around the earth far
sooner than we ever thought possible
and everything is just lined up just
perfectly to allow for an abundance of
life to essentially flourish here on
earth I mean it's also worth mentioning
that our moon is so unique and of itself
that it's the only moon in our solar
system or even in the observable
universe for that matter that has a
nearly perfect circular orbit
technically still elliptical however
there is no other moon that orbits its
planet that we have ever seen like ours
does now let me dump some coincidences
on you take the ratio 108 if you divide
the distance from the earth to the Sun
and divide it by the sun's diameter you
get 108 well the same thing with the
moon divide the distance from the moon
by its diameter and you also get 108
which is interesting because 108 is
mentioned in ancient civilizations
whether it be the 108 towers in Cambodia
or the significance of 108 in the Hindu
religion or even 108 that might have
some similarities to the Stonehenge
monuments with the outer perimeter
equaling 100.8 feet and all of these
things allow for a near perfect solar
eclipse well perfect to within 99.9
percent but the coincidences don't stop
there in fact the Sun and Moon appear
the same size in the sky because the
sun's diameter is about 400 times
greater but the Sun is also 400 times
further away but not only that the Earth
rotates at a speed 400 times faster than
the Moon and another number 366 the
Earth spins 366 times during one year
and the polar circumference of the earth
is 360 times bigger than that of the
Moon for the sake of brevity I'll stop
there but the coincidences don't just
stop there is unbelievable just how
perfect everything is between the Earth
and the moon these perfect alignments
the mass of the moon and it's perfect
orbit and distance from the earth have
allowed for incredible amounts of life
for the tides for the seasons and
although I'm not saying that the earth
would look anything like these other
places we've landed on without the moon
it sure is interesting on how grateful
we should be for well whatever put the
moon in its place when in
it did but there's other outstanding
questions about the moon such as the
Apollo 10 mission where they did that
practice run where they did a lap around
the moon prior to the Apollo 11 mission
where the astronauts overheard what they
described as music there was a rhythm
it was incredible like nothing they've
ever heard and he spent the better part
of an hour while on the far side of the
moon discussing this and that's when
they heard it while they were on the far
side of the moon so it couldn't have
been anything coming from Planet Earth
and although I'm not suggesting that
it's aliens on the moon listening to
music all I know is that the astronauts
were freaked out about it and they spent
the better part of an hour discussing
whether they would even share that with
NASA for fear of what it would do to
their careers and you know what NASA did
they kept this story secret for nearly
50 years that's kind of a red flag to me
and to throw even greater mystery into
the moon are you familiar with what's
called lunar transient phenomena where
dating back to the eleven hundreds
there's been several notable occasions
where people on earth have observed
glowing lights and for fluorescent
lighting on the moon many of which
cannot be explained through meteorites
which would you know maybe be a
flashlight or even volcanic activity
which would be sustained glowing red you
know lighting which has been observed
which some which has never been proved
to be volcanic activity by the way but
take for example the Apollo 11 mission
Buzz Aldrin Neil Armstrong there on the
way to the moon just hours from stepping
foot on it people back on the earth are
planning their barbecues meanwhile NASA
calls to Apollo 11 to say that through
their telescopes he observed some sort
of glowing greenish light on the north
side of the moon immediately Michael
Collins radios back and they were
observing it as well and he's described
it as a slight for fluorescent lighting
and in this story was just never heard
from again they didn't make it
classified it's not secret but you would
expect that to be a headline of some
sort I mean think about this just hours
from stepping foot on the moon for the
first time has only been several notable
occasions of these lights ever being
seen and it just so happens from the
first time we're ever going to set foot
on the moon this is observed by NASA
from Earth as well as the astronauts and
that are about to land there and the
story just gets you know omitted from
the headlines all together isn't that
interesting maybe we should go back to
the moon and look at these places where
these lights have been seen from maybe
we should go back to the moon and figure
out why the moon craters are so shallow
why there's process
metals or uranium 236 in neptunium 237
add all these things together guys you
get some really interesting conclusions
anyways guys it's time we start asking
serious questions about the moon it's
time we start entertaining the fact that
you know maybe it was geo engineered by
some advanced race who knows how long
ago I mean I know this sounds crazy but
when you could take into consideration
all the impossible coincidences well I
mean maybe it's not impossible but do
you think it's just a coincidence I sure
don't anyways guys I'll leave it at that
like and subscribe leave me a comment
let me know what your thoughts are and
I've many other videos to come and a
whole wide variety of topics
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight take
care everybody